christmas mary crimson debuts this
friday and jc
is live with a preview of that hey jc
hey kendall and rocky merry christmas to
you thanksgiving that's the fly over
holiday we're already thinking about
christmas here at red rock and i'll tell
you what
clark griswold would be so proud of the
setup here inside uh crimson i'm sorry
merry chrisman
merry christman it is unbelievable and
actually joe here is with redrock so
what inspired you guys to to make this
creation
i think after the year everybody's had a
little bit of holiday and cheer
like how can you go wrong with that you
can't go wrong you walk in the beautiful
lights and let's walk inside to crimson
here and
everything there's so many instagram
worthy spots we have the santa swing
yep it's our first video in our first
photo moment it's americans and swing
and then you'll see there's another
christmas story vignette right behind
you guys
swing away swing away you're doing a
very good job at swinging let's slide on
here because uh
over here we have this gigantic
gingerbread house tell me about this
house how many hours went into making
this
150 hours 10 team members and 50 pounds
of gingerbread
all edible from what you see can we get
a shot look at the attention to detail
inside this thing the furniture inside
is that edible
the furniture is not edible but
everything else is edible inside
i got about 30 seconds jonathan let's
spin around to the bar because you got
some
christmas treats what are the drinks
that we're looking at so the first one's
a gingerbread mule
followed by the nutcracker and then
drink up grinches
and and these are can you get these
non-alcoholic as well yes you can so if
you've been nice this year we can do the
non-alcoholic but for our naughty guests
they're definitely they need a little
alcohol and there's a great setup
outside actually with s'mores and fire
pits and we'll show you guys more of the
uh the setup outside coming up in the
four o'clock hour
but in the meantime we'll send it back
to you guys in the studio
drink up grinches good stuff
thanks jc we're going to check back in
with you during the 4 pm newscast
as well all right